BEN WEISSMANN: UROP is
Undergraduate Research
Opportunities Program, and it's
basically just a fancy
word for undergraduate
research.
So the idea is that
undergraduates can work with
grad students and professors
on their research.
Now, it's having
lots of issues.
It's being really about
recognizing--
YIHUI SAW: I started out at
MIT as a math major, but I
started dabbling a little
with programming.
And I found that I was really
interested in it.
And I was looking through some
of the projects at the Media Lab,
and I found this really
awesome project that has that
sort of interaction with
technology that is the vision
in the future.
BEN WEISSMANN: The basic idea is
to use computers to augment
physical spaces.
Instead of just altering how
you perceive reality, it
actually changes reality by
projecting on top of it.
YIHUI SAW: You have the
computer, the projector, and
the cameras built into one.
BEN WEISSMANN: You take the idea
like the form factor of a
light bulb, and then instead
of having a filament, you
replace that with cameras
and projectors and
that sort of stuff.
So it doesn't just shine light
down, it can see everything
and then react to that and
project different things down
instead of just plain light.
RONY KUBAT: LuminAR brings
together electrical
engineering, mechanical
engineering, computer science.
We've had UROPs in each of these
different disciplines.
NATHAN LINDER: So if I don't
want to go to the database and
edit or whatever--
YIHUI SAW: Yeah, like the most
recent week that we have on
the database.
NATHAN LINDER: OK, that's
a great solution.
Let's just do that.
The deal is very simple.
It's a team and everybody gets
responsibility and gets thrown
to the deep, cold water
very quickly, and
they need to swim.
It doesn't mean you let people
drown, but it means they need
to chart their course and teach
themselves. In the process
we learn a lot.
YIHUI SAW: We could also
pull some from
the performance records.
One of my roles in the project
is to explore what the system
can do. The Natura app was
really to demonstrate how
quickly you could develop
on the system.
I was told Natura coming the day
before, and I just started
pulling information from
the website and
built it within a day.
BEN WEISSMANN: You mark a region
that you're interested
in, which what you think of as
a button, and then it watches
your hand, and any time a hand
goes over that button it fires
off an event, and then we can
respond to those events.
YIHUI SAW: You could project the
color of the makeup right
onto your skin itself and
compare to skin tone.
BEN WEISSMANN: It's not so far
off from the future that it's
incomprehensible that we have
this in our homes in 5, 10
years, but it's still futuristic
enough that it's a
really, really cool
research topic.
RONY KUBAT: A lot of web
technologies are developing so
quickly that some of our UROPs
have come in, this is sort of
what they grew up as their first
languages, and so they
have a fluency with them
that we don't have yet.
BEN WEISSMANN: One of the big
benefits of UROP is that it
gives you a lot of hands-on
experiences verses classes
where you have these very
structured projects.
It's like, oh, you do this, and
then you get a grade on it
and it's either right
or wrong.
And what's cool about research
is that you don't
have a right or wrong.
You come up with an idea, and
you have a goal, and then you
work towards it and have
a product at the end.
So you have something that you
can actually show for it
instead of some little
class project.
YIHUI SAW: The research is
really cutting edge, and to be
involved could really help you
gain the skills and knowledge
that you don't get from a
classroom experience.
RONY KUBAT: The project is too
big for any one or two person
to do on their own.
It would not have been possible
without our UROPs.